- Ici, on injecte le CO2 pour
faire la carbonatation, une fois
que c'est prêt, la bière est
- C'est jour d'embouteillage
à la brasserie Lamememe.
Une petite et jeune entreprise,
qui cultive aussi une partie
nécessaires à la fabrication de
sasasa bière.
- C'est exactement le format
s'est rapidement imposé
dans lplplplan d'affaire.
JONATHAN THIBAULT, co-proprio
Brasserie La Ferme
- On est peut-être un peu
"old school". Ce qui est
vraiment aussi important
pour n
environnemental. On a consulté
des études, on a essayé de
comprendre qu'est-ce qui était
le meilleur entre les deux
à la conclusion que la bouteille
réutilispapapaparce qu'on peut
laver nos bouteilles, c'était le
meilleur choix.
le contenant à remplissage
multiple, comme la bouteille
brune, génère des impacts
environnemensisisisisisisisisiss
à celui à remplissage unique,
comme la canette d'aluminium,
notamment, parce que cette
au Québec.
- Donc le ré f f f final.
- La bouteille à remplissage
multiple, elle, peut être
parfois plus de 25. Mais elle n.
- Est-ce que vous vous êtes déjà
faits dire part t t t t t t t t?
- Oh oui, c'est arrivé.
Il y a des détaillants qui ont
fait le choix de ne vendre que
♪ ♪ ♪
- Dapepepepepermarché,
on accorde une grande place
aux produits de la bière,.......
- C'est ça.
- Sur les deux étages?
- Sur les deux étages.
- Mêmeopopopopopopopopopopopopoe
la bouteille représente
un bien plus grand casse-tête.
comme ressource, gérer cesboute?
JASEN GAOUETTE, pdg,
Alimentation v v v v v v v v v é
qui va repayer la consigne.
Après, ça, il va y avoir de la
manutention pour pouvoir la
va nous prendre des contenants,
une boîte ochchchchchchose comme
ça pour pouvoir les classer.
Après ça, il faut la retournerst
pas des microbrasseries queje v.
Je me retrouve que je maintiens
de l'inventaire tatatatatatatati
qu'il est plus simple de mettre
en valeur la canette, qui prend
moins d'espace.
bouffe. On fait notre bon
travail de citoyenf,f,f,f,f,f,
d'être récupérateur payeur et de
pouvoir retourner tous ces
notre fonction, notre fonctioni.
- La bouteille brune
à remplissage m
c'est au coeur du plan d'affaire
de Noël Gauthier.
- Les bouteilles arrivent dans
des caisses. Après ça, elles
embarquent sur un convoyeur.
à la fine pointe de la
technologie, osssssss
efficacement et à plus grandevit
ses preuves au Québec depuis
le début du 19e siècle.
NOËL GAUTHIER, co-fondateur
- Un coup qu'elles sont entrées
dans notre
qu'elles sont lavées à 80°,
la beauté, c'est que quand elle
dans un bac, qui s'en va chezuna
nettoyer, refondre le verre pour
pouvoir leququququququququququqs
chez les verriers pour pour
refaire des bouteilles.
Donc quand on parlait tout à
ad vitam aeternam du verre,
ça en est un
- Noël Gauthier croit aussi que
les contenants à remplissage
multiple ont un avenir certain,
enoboboboboboboboblèmes actuels
d'approvisionnement.
- On pense qu'il va y avoir r rs
à partir de 2022, 2023, 2024,
dans l'aluminium, autant que
dans le verre, ce qui nous
permet-e-e-e-e-e-e-e-e-e-e-e-e-r
de l'emploi, de l'économie, ma
aussi va éviter des ruptures de
marchandise de bouteilles dans
BENOIT CHARETTE, ministre de
l'Enviccccccccc
- Pour ce qui est de la bière,
il n'y a pas de changements.
bouteilles de bière pourronttoux
commerçants, en plus d'être
rapportédededededededededededed.
- Cette spécialiste craint
toutefois que les besoins
des brasseurs qui utilisent
ne soient pas pris en compte
lorsque la c
él
bière ne font pas partie de la
plupart des projets-pilotes.
AMÉLIE CÔTÉ, anal
réduction à la source, Équiterre
- Si ces points de dépôts
à intégrer les contenants
àipipipipipipipipipiples,
puis à bien les trier aussi
pour pas qu'ils brisent,
identifiable, bien là, ça peutai
ont des problèmes d'espace.
- Mais d d d d d d d d d d d d t
aussi envoyer un signal.
- Si on est conscient et
consciente finalement du fait
versus une cannette, je ne pensn
est si connue que ça à ce stade-
ci, maisôôôôôôôôôôôôôôôôôôôôôôô,
il faut aussi qu'il y ait
l'offre sur les tablettes.
- Contenant pour contenant,
de canettes que de bouteilles
de verre
c'est une plus grande facilité
du point de vue de la gestion,
type de contenants là. l l l l e
brasseurs qui sont tannés d'en
faire, maiititititititititititi.
Si tout le monde demande la
bouteille, ça se pourrait que
tout le monde en fasse